[Applause]
defensively in front of him it's thomas
horton tucker he's going to look to get
into the lane
wants to step back he's boxed in back to
kuzma still all kinds of time
12 seconds left stu kuzma gets into it
here he goes
two steps and score linker's lead
houston has a timeout they'll spend it
123
122 just 6.9
remaining yeah but the quick striking
rockets have had the answer again
let's see what the lakers can do with
one defensive sequence of only seven
seconds
actually 6.9 as cruz just takes kenyan
martin
jr off the dribble the extra little step
there during the sidestep
and he gets to basically a layup puts
the lakers up
by one let's
see what the rockets come back with who
will they have being their
trigger man well olynyk's had a good
game martin jr of course has come on
brooks was
red-hot for a long time side out right
in front of us
laker lead is one augustine got to get
it in and does to olynyk
olynyk will turn with four with three
kelly olynyk loses
it foul lakers are going to want to end
up winning it
that's what happened because frank vogel
put a guard in to guard
kelly olynyk and wesley matthews when
kelly olynyk
tried to take wesley matthews off to
dribble had some problems
wesley matthews says no i ain't having
it you're not beating me off the dribble
reaches in and tips it free here's the
play
watch watch wesley matthews reach in
knock it free
turnover ball into the hands of tht free
throws coming with
0.9 so uh
successive nights wesley matt b